So which is it
I know bix has a game i know you bribe
quartermasters to leave valuables on the ships
before they come in for scrap but this isn't
that this isn't something that that pass
no i went in and got this myself how how's that
possible it was it was sealed on the imperial
naval base in stair guard look you got the money
i got the box what else is there to talk about
i'll give you another thousand credits to tell
me how you got it another thousand done how
you just walk in like you belong takes more than
that doesn't it but to steal from the empire
what do you need a uniform some dirty hands and an
imperial token they're so proud of themselves they
don't even care they're so fat and satisfied they
can't imagine it can't imagine why that someone
like me would ever get inside their house walk
their floors spit in their food take their gear
they're so proud of themselves
so fat and satisfied
these days will end there
will be no rules going forward
people are standing up
that's what a reckoning sounds like
Welcome back
everyone it's charlie this will be my new star
wars and or video they dropped a new trailer with
a whole bunch of new footage so we'll break it
down if you're brand new to the channel i will
be doing star wars and or videos for all the
episodes they're going to be starting in a couple
weeks so be sure to subscribe to get all those
that's right pretty soon we'll have new star wars
and or episodes along with house of the dragon
she-hulk and a bunch of other stuff at the same
time too like lord of the rings episodes like
it's a bonanza of episodes it's a wonder that i
can keep up with everything it'll be fun to try
and make videos for all that stuff but in the
new clip cassie and andor is pulling a job for
stellen skarsgard's luthen character who's a high
ranking member inside the empire it's not totally
clear if he's also a member of the senate too like
mon mothma but he is a high ranking figure that
seems like he has a place on coruscant because we
see him there during the trailer too with a whole
bunch of finery like he's putting a bunch of rings
on he has a bunch of jewelry he's also meeting mon
mothma so coruscant itself and the imperial senate
will be a big location during the series because
they didn't actually disband the imperial senate
to like the events of a new hope like when darth
vader captured princess leia's corellian corvette
that they had just disbanded the imperial senate
they all said it will no longer be of any concern
to us i have just received word that the emperor
has dissolved the council permanently the bix that
he's referring to is adrian arjona's character we
haven't had too much footage of her but she's
in a couple trailer scenes she's meant to be
cassie and andor's on-again off-again girlfriend
like they've broken each other's hearts and then
gotten back together several times over so they'll
just have a lot of history when the show picks up
but it sounds like they're both working inside
the resistance together that's basically what
the rebellion was called when it was just
a bunch of pockets of resistance literally
the show itself is meant to show you the formation
of the rebellion because they didn't actually call
them the rebellion until much later in the
timeline like even during the events of star
wars rebels which is like right before a new hope
they were still called the resistance what they're
doing though is that in season two of star wars
and or like they've already announced that they're
doing season two and they've started filming the
episodes is that every couple of episodes they'll
jump an extra year in the timeline so that by the
end of season two they'll be at the events of star
wars rogue one but lutheran is asking cassie and
andor how he got this special item like this box
from inside an imperial naval facility and lets us
know what some of his tactics are in his pocket of
the resistance now he himself is meant to be a
specialist in this area like every person that's
part of the resistance doesn't have as easy a time
grabbing stuff from inside the empire as he does
he just happens to be very good at it but stellen
skarsgard's lutheran character also lets us know
some of the resistance tactics and they kind of
use the empire against itself or greedy members
of the empire against the empire saying that he
knows that their resistance bribes the imperial
quartermasters on ships to leave special items
so they can just steal them the imperial naval
base that he refers to is on a planet called sir
guard or it's in a place called stir guard it's
not clear if it's a planet or just a place and i
believe it's meant to be brand new for the show
because i haven't found a version of it online
yet there are couple locations that we see in the
trailer so it could be one of these locations and
he gives cassie in a bunch more credits to learn
about how he's able to steal such a high value
item from inside the imperial naval base when
nobody else should be able to do that and this is
a big eye-opening moment for stellen skarsgard's
character where he's like wait a minute you can
just walk in there and act like you're part of
the empire and nobody will look twice at you in
the speech that cassian gives him is part of the
voice over in the trailers that you probably heard
before where he talks about how the empire has
gotten so fat and lazy most of them even wouldn't
consider that it's possible for someone like him
to just waltz in and take something from them so
during this part of the timeline security has just
become very relaxed because the empire has grown
so big and so powerful since the events of revenge
of the sith all the officers all the rank and file
people just think the empire is too big to fail
so it doesn't even cross their mind also a funny
thing here cassie andor implies that he actually
spits in their food when he's sneaking around
inside these imperial facilities so best double
check your food or don't leave it unattended
that'll make you paranoid so a big part of the
series is showing you how things come together
and how they basically use the empire against
itself like it's grown so big and there's so many
complacent people inside of it they're either
willing to help or either just don't care and
will let them do whatever they want to so that's
how the resistance is able to get a lot of their
supplies they literally just bogart it from the
empire in fact they're kind of doing that in the
mandalorian timeline where bokeh tank crees has
been trying to marshal enough forces stealing from
moff gideon in the remnants of the empire's forces
technically it's grand admiral thrawn's forces
i think he would overrule moff gideon but when
you're talking about imperial ranks next to the
emperor the most powerful people inside the empire
are either grand moffs or grand admirals who are
about the same in power level but their spheres
of influences like their actual jobs are very very
different so like unless you're in the middle of
a large battle you're not going to see a grand
admiral interacting with the grand moff giving
one another orders and someone like darth vader
kind of has a special position inside the empire
where he's powerful enough to basically tell grand
moffs and grand admirals what to do but he doesn't
have an official position like he himself doesn't
have an actual rank and the funny thing is is that
all the regular imperial navy people actually
really do not like darth vader at all like when
he tells them what to do or pushes them around
they really really hate that issues that they're
too afraid to speak out against him because
he will literally just force choke the life
out of anyone who displeases him but if we're
talking about the resistance using the empire
against itself during the series like turning
people inside the empire against the empire
the other funny side connection to darth vader is
that he himself actually did not care at all about
what happened to people in the empire he didn't
care about any of them he didn't care about the
inquisitors he hated the emperor the emperor and
darth vader never trusted each other and they
were always looking to outmaneuver one another
like the emperor always figured that darth vader
would betray him eventually and darth vader was
always looking for a way to get rid of the emperor
that was the whole thing he tried to do when
empire strikes back is use luke skywalker to
join forces with him so they could overthrow the
emperor but it's also why he was so quick to force
choke all these imperial officers just because
he didn't care about any of them the only thing
that darth vader actually cared about is his wife
padme because at least for most of the series he
thought that his children had died at birth it
was until right after the events of a new hope
based on some of the new comics in the canon
that he learned that luke skywalker was his son
like he came into the events of empire strikes
back already knowing that luke was his son
and then it wasn't till after that that he
learned that leia was also still alive as well
but they did say a lot of big legacy characters
would guest star on this series so i know people
are asking like is darth vader going to show up
will the emperor show up what about other really
major characters i believe that bail organa will
have some sort of cameo scene because the people
who are critical in the formation of the rebellion
and if that's what this series is all about were
mon mothma who we saw in the trailer obviously now
this lutheran character he's a brand new character
that they introduced for the series in an older
version of teenage princess leia and i don't know
what their plans are for doing a version of leia
because during the obi-wan kenobi series clearly
they did not have a problem doing a new version
of a very young leia but it's been a while since
we've had rogue one and the technology for doing
that weird deep fake is way better because of
all the luke skywalker stuff they've been doing
on the mandalorian but my guess is just because
of the touchy situation i think they're gonna try
and avoid doing as much princess leia as possible
but it's hard to do the formation of the
rebellion without featuring her so they do
feature her it might just be in the background
it might just be easter eggs and references
and if we see her on screen it might just be
a version in like the last couple of episodes
they kind of had a similar canon problem with the
obi-wan kenobi episodes because you were doing a
young version of leia she couldn't get too close
to darth vader because he would sense that she
was force sensitive and through the force start
to read her mind and find out who she really was
that's why all the scenes of her were on the
fortress inquisitorius when darth vader wasn't
there so like by the time she'd escaped that
was when darth vader showed up that was their
easy workaround for that problem this series is
meant to be a rogue one prequel and of all the new
movies rogue one looks closest to the way that the
original trilogy looked so this series is going
to look much closer to what the original trilogy
looked like just in terms of ships and technology
i've already done a couple trailer videos with
a bunch of different footage so i'll link those
below in the description my episode videos for
it will start after it premieres in september
it's going to be a three episode premiere too
it's 12 episodes total so it's like the longest
series that we've ever gotten from disney plus
from marvel or star wars and real big reminder
the mandalorian season 3 isn't going to start
till early february next year but we're probably
going to get the mandalorian season 3 trailer in
a couple weeks at the big disney plus day event
i will do videos for whatever they wind up
releasing there'll be a bunch of marvel trailers
and a bunch of star wars trailers too while you
wait for everything everyone click here for my
house of the dragon episode 2 trailer video and
click here for my full she-hulk episode 2 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!